having a personal server rack for a
non-enterprise individual at home can be
a bit cost prohibitive starting with the
cost of the rack itself and going down
the line of components it has long been
a dream of mine to have a server rack
but up until very recently i really
never thought it would happen but if it
did happen should it be enclosed open 2
post 4 post 25 rack units tall 15u
42u after watching prices on craigslist
ebay amazon and others for well over a
year i stumbled on this four post 42u
open star tech rack for an incredible
270 dollars and i'll put links in the
description for everything mentioned
here so if you're interested in checking
out more or getting the same things as
me
definitely check out the description of
the video i honestly thought there was
probably a mistake or something like
that like this was a mislisting or
something i was just looking up the rack
that daniel had just bought you know the
co-author of the normal hours from
scratch book nnfs.io and i couldn't help
but notice how cheap this four post 42u
was it was actually cheaper than most of
the smaller variants and normally this
one is like 400 plus dollars so i had no
choice and i bought it now the real
thing to really push me over the edge
and start thinking about actually
building a home lab was this concept of
network area storage or nas
at this point i have over seven machines
but for sure seven machines and like 30
different drives of varying sizes spread
across many rooms and various transfer
speeds and i say for sure because i have
other machines that sometimes i turn on
and sometimes i don't or like laptops
stuff like that but seven like real
machines that are constantly running
doing things and yes 30 plus drives like
again i'm not counting some of the
drives because i might not use them
anymore but it's a lot of information a
lot of stuff is spread around uh it's
it's a huge pain with things like neural
network model sizes themselves often
gigs or bigger in size alone and you
generally when you're training or even
transfer learning you're trying to save
like a bunch of those models as you go
on and then data sets themselves are
often terabytes in size now
i just i wanted more storage but i also
really want to centralize all that
storage and and try to eke out the best
read and write speeds that i can out of
that especially given that now i own a
few machines with 10 gigabit so i knew i
wanted an as and you could do a desktop
nas or rack mount nas but the fact that
i wanted a nas i was like that that's
really what pushed me over the edge to
make me think you know what i should
actually start rack building i've got
all these machines all these computers
networking power all these things are
hugely problematic so i should really
build a rack so this is what pushed me
over the edge so in
pre-built rack mount nasland there's
mainly qnap and synology now qnap is at
least currently 30 to 50 cheaper than
synology for like the same thing but
this probably has something to do with
the public sentiment towards qnap given
fairly recent and close together attacks
and ransomware on their devices
along with arguably poor public
communication around these events then
you have synology it's twenty four
hundred dollars for a driver list so it
doesn't come with the actual drives 12
bay nas unit and then if you want 10
gigabit you got to buy a separate 150
network card for 10 gigabit also these
rack mount nas units can often sound
like jet engines this is because they're
generally the smallest form factor that
they can get they've got these very
small fans and you want to generate high
airflow and generally these are expected
to be running in a data center not
another room that a human lives or works
in but i want to put this rack into the
same room that i'm recording videos like
this one on so i priced out building my
own 12 bay hot swappable unit with 10
gigabit for sixteen hundred dollars
beyond this it's going to be far more
quiet completely customizable going
forward and more powerful i can also
very easily repurpose this entire thing
for some other use case it doesn't have
to always be a nas so the case that i
went with is this 4u rose will 12 bay
hot swappable unit the only downside of
this case was that like cover for the
hard drives uh it has a key and it's
locked and
i the case did not come with a key there
is no key
so i ended up actually prying this open
now the good news is i didn't intend to
use this anyways i actually
wanted to take it off and i did find out
how to take off that case cover but if
you did want that case cover and that
lock just to kind of block away like the
usb and stuff or just the drives they
are hot swappable so it'd be very quick
and easy to like take a drive so if you
wanted that functionality um maybe watch
out for the case of the missing key but
also just know that this was like
unbelievably simple to pry open like i
just basically pulled it and it came
open
i didn't have to try very hard but
otherwise i really do like the case and
like i said i had no intention of using
that cover anyways the motherboard that
i went with is a gigabyte z590 master
and this was 200 and it comes with 10
gigabit given that a 10 gigabit card
alone is 150
this seemed like quite this deal along
with that it has six onboard sata and
16x 8x and 4x pcie again i might want to
repurpose this and use that 16x one day
for a gpu for example and it's just nice
to have that there as an option i'm also
going to use the 4x pcie for a sata
expansion
so i have the six on board ports and i
need at least six more to expand to the
12 you know hot swappable drives but
then i want a operating system disc for
the nas i also probably want a redundant
operating system disk and then another
one for cash
the socket on this motherboard is lga
1200 so i had quite a few options but i
went with an intel core i5 11 600k
this is more than enough to power this
nas but i will admit this is like the
weakest processor i've bought in a long
time
for power this is where i went the most
overboard i got a corsair rm 850x gold
850 watts is massively overkill here it
will never draw that much as a nas but i
just can't stomach buying anything less
since i may indeed one day wish to stuff
a decent gpu in here repurpose it or
maybe have this unit as a multi-purpose
unit
or maybe i just buy another nas later on
or something like that i'd rather just
be able to be lazy about how much work
is entailed and i just don't like a
something like a 300 or like a 500 watt
psu that can really only power machines
like this and getting a little more
wattage out of the power supply is not
very expensive for ram nothing special
here two 16 gigabit
gigabit two 16 gigabyte sticks of ddr4
ram this is plenty comfy for the use
case here i never purchased any quiet
fans but noctua fans came in the fractal
design casing for the workstation that i
got from puget and i'll put a link to
that build in the description but i
think the biggest thing that like really
blew me away about that build and it's a
very high performance build
it was how quiet it was i work right
next to it and i simply
do not hear it but it can keep two 30
90s cool no problem
so this completely reversed my stance on
quiet fans and quiet pc builds and for
this build i bought some knock to a 120
millimeter and 80 millimeter fans to
replace the fans that the case came with
finally for the actual storage i have
four 18 terabyte exos enterprise hard
disks uh for this i was really looking
for yes bulk storage but then also i was
kind of just pricing out the cost per
terabyte and 18 terabytes was pretty
fair
eight terabytes 10 terabytes especially
the 10 terabyte disk for some reason uh
were quite expensive per terabyte and
then also they just recently ish came
out with 20 terabyte discs so these are
also kind of expensive i think as people
are rushing to get the highest amount
per so i went with 18 and this is plenty
comfy to start with now to power this
nas and the rest of my rack i had wiring
for 30 amps at 240 volts on a dedicated
breaker with a 30 amp 240 volt power
distribution unit that could
theoretically provide me with 7.2
kilowatts of total power
and that's off a single outlet and
single cable going to the rack then this
pdu would distribute that amongst all of
the machines in the rack so i hunted for
a 30 amp 240 volt power supply and i
landed on this one unfortunately that
listing is a bit inaccurate it's
actually not 30 amps it's 24 and we can
confirm this by looking at the official
documentation for this unit that said
i'm okay with this for now it's kind of
hard to find a 30 amp at 240 volts where
you actually get the full 7.2 kilowatts
most of the units that i could find
leading up to this and even after i
found out that this one was 24 amps they
still all seem to claim that peak power
of 5.8 or 5.7 and some change kilowatts
so i think this is about as good as i'm
going to get for now unless i'm ready to
spend some serious coin
but even so i still have an unused 20
amp 240 volt outlet on its own breaker
entirely as well
so if i do somehow max out this 5.8
kilowatts i've got plenty more to work
with the specific pdu has both c13 and
c19 receptacles you probably recognize
the c13 and then maybe c19 if you have a
higher wattage psu the typical power
cables at least in the united states are
going to be something like c13 to a nema
515 well this is problematic because we
don't have any nema plugs or nema
receptacles on the pdu that i bought so
instead you either have to buy new power
cables or a cable that's going to
convert from nema to the c variants at
least for me i bought new cables just so
i could get the exact lengths that i
wanted
so for now my power problem is solved
beyond power distribution and storage uh
the next order of business is networking
i have a lot of devices with varying
speeds and the needs of those speeds but
i've got a solid four ish machines that
i'd like to have networked at as high
rate as possible or at least financially
reasonable
but the more the merrier and i have lots
of switches one pretty old switch that
is like 100 megabits per second with 24
ports and then another one with 16
gigabit ports and then that 16
ports with gigabit anyway
and then i have some other switches and
stuff floating around but that said i
now have five 10 gigabit capable
machines that i like the backbone of my
local you know network and my office
area i'd like that to be 10 gigabit
possible and 10 gigabit switches are
expensive and it's hard to even just
find switches with more than like two or
four 10 gigabit ports and then the rest
will be like 2.5 or one but i did find
this tp link with eight 10 gigabit ports
for a pretty good price it's still
fairly painful but uh for 10 gigabit
it's actually a really good price so i
went with that one for the main switch
and kind of the backbone that said i'll
be reserving these ports for machines
with 10 gigabit only and it only if i
actually need that speed uh there are
plenty of machines where there's just no
need for 10 gigabit but mostly i'm
trying to use that for things like video
editing or the machines that i need to
move data sets or lots of models on to
and from all that kind of stuff so for
sure i will have the nas network there a
couple of my deep learning computers
there my main computer for like video
editing stuff like that will all be on
there but then i've got other switches
for things that just simply don't need
that much next as a sort of a side but
not really are the sliding rails so i
went with these universal rails from
star tech sliding rails are super cool
but either extremely expensive and still
needing to be like retrofitted to the
case that you intend to use i will say
some cases and equipment do come with
quality rails it's not like they they
don't exist but it's just pretty rare it
seems and then the ones that you can get
are either unbelievably expensive or
just way too untrustworthy to risk
multi-thousand dollar machines falling
on yet more multi-thousand dollar
machines in a cascading fashion so to
help me sleep at night i went with
something i can actually just put my
faith in and i got these uh universal
rails from star tech for things like the
switches and stuff like that ear
mounting is totally fine same thing with
like the pdu that's ear mounted but for
heavier things like the nas unit and
some of the computers i'm going to be
putting in there i definitely want
something that is trustworthy for the
software side of the nas i've gone with
trunas 13. i put the operating system on
two solid state drives for redundancy
and then i've got another 240 gigabyte
ssd for cash
i found a super helpful video for
setting things up in truenas i'll put a
link to that in the description what i
will say is i came at this knowing
really nothing about raid other than
what it stands for and daniel suggested
to me raid z1 for four discs at a time
and that's what i did with raid z1 the
one is tolerant for one disk failing and
no data loss in that v dev i'm going to
build my pool of disks four at a time
with each four making up one v dev or
virtual device in the end i'll have 12
total disks three v devs and each v dev
will have four discs each each with one
tolerant to failure in that v dev i'm
starting off with these four 18 terabyte
drives in raid z1 so that gives me
approximately 50 terabytes of storage to
start with and each v dev that i add
will be another 50 terabytes for a total
of about 150 terabytes of storage in
this case now that might sound like a
lot already i will say i've only i'm
just starting with 50 terabytes for now
but i already have over 25 terabytes of
storage spread across
many machines and that's with me being
fairly brutal about removing data sets
models especially things like when i
pre-process data sets um i i toss the
pre-processing and keep the raw data set
just for storage purposes but it would
be very nice to be able to save those
pre-processed data sets as well so i
definitely look forward to being a bit
more comfy with storage and honestly
expect to fill out 50 terabytes
pretty quick so after feeling for years
like my own server rack was a bit
outrageous and even more so like a 42
unit rack like how am i ever going to
fill that um i'm left feeling like
i should have done this a really long
time ago
i've for so long had five separate
machines that i use very much
simultaneously and it's very difficult
to manage them in like every way the
data the i o
networking and even just powering them
and not tripping breakers um like when i
plug in a vacuum or something like that
so i've had to distribute them across
multiple rooms and then that also that
distribution makes all the other things
hard like io and networking and all that
the rack just solves all this and just
makes a lot of sense as a form factor it
also is going to wind up reducing the
space usage of basically all my other
machines are like workstation e
desktop-e type machines whereas in this
case it's like i'm able to stack all of
my machines in one one spot there's also
a definite kind of cool factor i suppose
to customizing the entire rack and just
kind of like planning things out i've
got an excel spreadsheet essentially
where i've marked all the units you know
each cell is a rack unit for example and
i'm just kind of planning out where i'm
going to put everything and all of that
and just being like such a modular form
factor i'm just finding it really
enjoyable to like plan and engineer out
the layout and and everything that goes
along with that so truly just like
making a custom rack just for me just
what i want i spent a lot of time
looking at things like home lab on
reddit and stuff like that and it seemed
like like everyone's rack was something
that like i just didn't understand like
why would you want that in your rack
like what's that doing for you and it
just made me feel like what would i need
a rack for i don't need any of those
things that these other people are
putting in their rack why would i need
that you know and then like i don't know
one day it just kind of clicked and it's
like wow i got a lot of computers and
compute and
storage and all these things that man i
really wish that was in a rack and the
networking and all that kind of stuff
and then like all of a sudden it's like
oh
yeah it's like completely customizable
it's just like a computer like it's you
make it whatever it is that you want so
anyways i'm finding that really cool and
there's like so many unique things that
you can add to your rack and stuff like
that and anyway i'm just really looking
forward to continuing this build and
sharing the journey with you all because
this is just the beginning and to be
honest i
pretty much already know how i'm going
to fill this entire rack
so stay tuned for that and till next
time
you